hundreds protested against the possible  covet-related mandates last night among  those gathered were some ccsd employees  they're concerned with a recent school  board decision allowing superintendent  jarrah to create a vaccine mandate for  employees no official policy has been  made yet  the organizers of this event say they  don't agree with any coven mandates  across the valley  the end of the day we all just want to  live our lives unrestricted and being  able to have the freedom to do what we  want  some at the rally were also involved in  a ccsd walkout employees called out to  protest the vaccine mandate ccsd says it  strives to create a safe and healthy  environment